[Music]
bad times at the El Royale is a frantic
film that breaks the mold in many ways
with the movie being so long many may
have left at the air as the screen fades
to black and miss the final scene that
follows the film I thought I'd give my
breakdown about ending scene to let you
know if you missed anything and of
course there will be heavy spoilers with
that out the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to buy
the film's clothes there have been many
murders and the only two characters left
standing or pretend priest of Daniel
Flynn and singer Darlene sweet the two
join forces during the mayhem and
decided to split the stolen cash that
Daniel Flynn was after Darlene was only
staying at the hotel before a
performance in Reno so it makes sense
that Flynn would trust her and want to
partner up with her to make it through
the events of the film the cult leader
played by Chris Hemsworth that really
put them through the wringer but there
was definitely a friendship formed and
this is confirmed in the final scene of
the film Darlene finally makes it to
Reno to perform and we can see Daniel
Flynn in the crowd watching over her
there - given not to each other similar
to how Alfred does - Bruce at the end of
The Dark Knight Rises except that one
made me cry and this one just made me
think I can't believe I sat through 2
hours and 20 minutes for this it was
alright though I suppose in a recent
interview with what culture a director
Drew Goddard stated that my hope for the
film is that people can relate to the
different characters at different times
in the movie when we started to screen
the film we found that people had
allegiance with one character and then
their allegiance changes and changes
again and again personally I'm glad they
both made it to the end because everyone
else will see that Saul Goodman or
Hannibal Lecter or someone else that I
just hate like that kid who bullied me
at school I'll never forget you Timmy
Thompson I will have my revenge
anyway this scene is a celebration of
their survival and in a way showcases
that they will both go on to
eat normal and happy lives debatably so
what did you think of the ending of bad
times at the El Royale were you
disappointed that you sat through what
was already a long movie just to get
another scene at the end or did you
enjoy it comment below and let me know
this is a channel for people who are mad
about movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe make sure
you check out my recent breakdown of the
ending of the new Halloween movie linked
at the end of this one and if you want
to support the channel so I can bring
you more videos like this check out my
patreon which is linked in the
description thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you